Se nos pide utilizar los menús desplegables para formar una ecuación lineal que no tenga soluciones,
o sea una ecuación lineal que no importa
cómo la manipulemos,
al final lo que tengamos a la izquierda no sea igual
a lo que tengamos a la derecha.
Y vamos a ver que opciones nos dan.
Primero debemos escoger un coeficiente para el término de "x" y luego debemos escoger la constante.
Si aquí ponemos "7x" tenemos "7x" en los
dos lados de la ecuación y aquí del lado
izquierdo tenemos "7x" menos 9, si escogemos
una constante diferente a -9, o sea si escogemos
este 7 aquí, no vamos a tener ninguna solución.
Y ustedes se podrían preguntar,
¿oye, cómo se te ocurrió eso?
Vamos a pensar, tenemos "7x" aquí del lado
izquierdo y "7x" del lado derecho,
si queremos resolverlo algebraicamente, restamos "7x"
de los dos lados y anulamos estos términos,
quitamos "7x" de los dos lados y todo lo que
nos queda es un 9 negativo igual a 7,
lo cual no es posible para ningún valor
de "x" que escojamos.
Otra forma de pensar en esto es decir, bueno,
aquí tengo un 7 multiplicado por cualquier
número y le restamos 9 y de este lado tengo
7 multiplicado por ese número y en lugar
de restarle 9, le sumamos 7, entonces no existe ningún valor de "x" para el que esto sea verdadero.
Vamos a checar nuestra respuesta.